في عربه صغيره يقوم عبد السلام بتجهيز
انواع من السمبوسه والمشروبات وبيعها
للماره في احد اسواق محافظه مارب اليمنيه
للعام الخامس على التوالي ينفذ هذا
المشروع الموسميه مع حلول شهر رمضان
ويكسب منه قوت اسرته اغلق عبد السلام محلا
تجاريا كان يصرع فيه هذه الاشياء لعدم
قدرته على دفع الايجار ووجد الخير في
مشروع صغير لا يكلفه شيئا حاله كحال كثير
من اليمنيين هذا المشروع افعله بدايه كل
رمضان كل سنه هذا الموسم الرابع او الخامس
تقريبا واعتمانا اعتمادنا عليه يعني بشكل
رسمي ومصاريف رمضان مصاريف العيد وكذا
والحمد لله ربك كريم مشي امورنا سابره
المشاريع البسيطه هي الناجحه وتوفر اكثر
بحيث انه ايجار المحلات غاليه بشكل كبير
هناك ما بعض الانسان ما يريد ما يدخل يوقع
له دخل الا في رمضان من دخل هذه المشاريع
الصغيره وتخفف عليه قبل موعد الافطار
تزدحم الشوارع بباعه الخضار والوجبات
الخفيفه الكل ينادي زبائنه عبر مكبرات
الصوت فطورك يا صائم
مشهد مالوف وتنافس بين المطاعم واصحاب
المشاريع الصغيره هذه التي يفضلها
المواطنون لانخفاض اسعارها ومسانده
اصحابها على الكسب والاستمرار قمنا بشوايه
في الشوارع ماشي معانا محلات
وخفضنا الاسعار من 4000 ريال في رمضان هذه
قبل المغرب بالذات لها طلب عند الناس
سمبوسه عصير
واشياء خفيفه وفيها الحمد لله مصدر رز
ممتاز
الحلويات الشعبيه يجد سوقها رواجا خلال
شهر رمضان
وتنتشر عشرات العربات لبيع اصناف معينه
منها في ظل الازمه المعيشيه تمثل هذه
المشاريع قوتها كثير من اليمنيين في رمضان
وتعد مصدر دخلهم الوحيد محمود الحميدي
العربيه مارب